Hey so I just got back from a taping of
the super Joel McHale on yeah I asked
him a question what is your favorite
street
I've heard of treats yes like it's not I
asked everyone on Twitter what they
thought Joel's favorite treat was not
correct let's see what you'll see
retreat is what is my favorite treat I'm
gonna go with sushi yep I like sushi
here's kinda weird that and a little bit
of a Seacrest hairspray oh come on you
are actually quite talented
yeah was Joel's favorite treat sushi
it's really treat whatever anyways check
out a few of the other celebrity
interviews that I've done what do you
think the treat and let me know in the
comments what celebrity you'd like me to
ask their favorite readers
I'll see if I can make it happen